I mean just speak how much poorer we
would be today if the world had had half
as many people in the 19th century as it
actually did you can get rid of either
Thomas Edison or Louis Pasteur take your
pick
hi i'm matt wells for recent TV i am
joined today by dr. robert zubrin author
of the new book merchants of despair
radical environmentalists criminal
pseudo-scientists and the fatal cult of
anti humanism thank you for joining us
today thanks for inviting me why are we
40 years after you know the population
bomb and a lot of the kind of most
dystopian environmentalists why go after
the hyperbole of activists in 2012
because they're still with us you know
look we have never been in danger of
running out of resources but we have
encountered considerable danger from
people who say we're running out of
resources and who say that human
activities need to be constrained
because there isn't enough to go around
and so someone's got to be put into
control okay this has been a threat for
some time and what I do in the book
merchants of despair is go through the
history of this movement over 200 years
and show the horrendous results of their
activities where they've been successful
now we've seen you know history of
eugenics and a lot of really just sort
of nasty awful stuff in the year 2012
where is this formulating policy wars
where threats arising from these kind of
as you describe the Manti humanist
tendencies well among the ongoing
programs that they have our population
control programs which involve the
forced sterilization of millions of
women every year where's that happening
Africa South America India Indonesia and
and that's under US pressure and in
China under their own pressure so the
u.s. is pressuring Indonesia to engage
in forced sterilization it's a condition
of getting foreign aid funds in the
1960s remnants of the pre-war eugenics
movement reorganized around the slogan
of population control and they always
fit their ideas to fit the time so they
said population control was necessary to
win the Cold War that excessive growth
of population in the third world would
provide masses for the Communist world
revolution and so that the US should
make population control part
of its foreign policy and in 1966 laws
were passed that mandated that US
foreign aid funds should be linked to
population control Johnson
administration denied famine aid to
India in 1967 unless Indira Gandhi
implemented forced sterilization
programs which she did and this was then
done in in many other countries with
horrific consequences in every place
where it's been implemented it's always
the the dominant race in the local place
doing it to the subservient race the
Brahmins against the untouchables and
seal on the soon relieves against the
Tamils in Peru this has been horrific
and it is still going on so conditional
of us a member to have forced
sterilization in order to get this money
in 2012 you have that population control
programs which typically have involved
forced sterilization or most typically
what they've involved is quotas for the
governments involved so that these
programs are top-down mandated and then
the people at the lower level in order
to meet their quotas you're out there
figure out how to do it whether it is
for sterilization whether it is denying
benefits like public schooling public
health to people who don't go along or
lying to you no not terribly well
educated women you know it's telling
them that this is a reversible operation
offering cash incentives to people who
are very poor okay so this is the
population control then we have the
general impairment of economic
development due to environmentalist
activity across a range of things from
nuclear power to genetically modified
foods to drilling for oil and and now of
course most recently we have the
proposal that human industrial and
activity should be limited to stop
global warming that's kind of failing or
at least as the current sort of treaty
status and trying to get India and China
on on board this thing it's reaching the
roadblock it's not like it's going
further under the Obama administration
than it did under george w bush is the
threat more what could happen later or
is it how it's translating in other kind
of non treaty level global warming
policies well the only reason why it
hasn't gone forward in the United States
is because the Republicans won the
election in 2010
what if they lose the election this year
you know you have a movement here which
is committed to giving the government
the power to ration the use of fire this
is a menace and to count upon a
fortunate election being repeated
endlessly would be folly I grew up in
Southern California couldn't see the
mountains when I was a kid we can see
the mountains now isn't some of that
regulation based or environmental policy
kind of Central Command based
results yes now there there's a
distinction to be made between practical
environmentalism which wants to for
instance stop people from dumping
industrial wastes into the reservoir
okay that is necessary to preserve a
sound living environment for people and
ideological environmentalism which seeks
to use instances of human damage to the
environment whether real or imagined to
further the case for the prosecution
that humans are vermin they're wrecking
the world and they've gotta be put under
control and so somebody's got to be put
in control those are two different
things with respect to regulations that
are necessary they should simply be
outcome based they should simply say
that you can't put this more than this
much nitric acid up your smokestack they
should not tell you how to run your
factory you know there are ways you can
modify automobiles right now very easily
to make them be able to get much more
mileage to be able to run on alternate
fuel such a methanol that are much
cheaper and be less polluting at the
same time they are illegal under the
Clean Air Act because the Environmental
Protection Agency will tell you that
you're tampering with a pollution
control device and if you say them well
I'll take the car in for emissions
testing and show you that it's cleaner
than your standards they say we don't
care and that's generally the approach
taken in environmental regulation right
it's here is the method and also the
destination as opposed to just reach
these targets by whatever non you know
coercive or not vote right by one thing
and by so doing that they are actually
crippling the ability of people to
improve the in
a final question there's in a lot of the
sort of discussion about about
Environmental Policy it boils down to or
feels like a boils down to between
people who say this is exists and people
who say it doesn't exist or it's being
exaggerated whether it's global warming
or whether it's it's you know Population
Bomb or other types of things do you
think that that framing if it's indeed
true has has allowed for free market
solutions to legitimate environmental
problems taking a backseat well in
general their desire to control
everything from the top has impaired
numerous technologies that could improve
the environment nuclear power for
example you know I used to work in the
nuclear industry and there was one plant
that was having a certain problem which
we knew exactly how to correct but we
couldn't do at the NRC wouldn't let us
because it meant deviating from their
regulations genetically modified crops
they have genetically modified crops now
that can produce their own pesticides
and fix their own nitrates so you don't
need to spray pesticides into the
environment and you don't need to
scatter nitrate fertilizer on the land
they won't let you do it look a lot of
things they say are happening but are
not problems population growth is
happening it's not a problem the world
standard of living has gone up as
population has increased and not
coincidentally it means a larger market
which allows people to introduce new
technologies faster a larger division of
labor a larger number of inventors
coming up with new technologies I mean
just think how much poorer we would be
today if the world had had half as many
people in the 19th century as it
actually did you can get rid of either
Thomas Edison or Louis Pasteur take your
pick okay
you know and if these people had been to
power if Malthus had had his way and we
could have limited the world's
population to the 1 billion people that
there were in the year 1800 an immense
amount of human progress that we're
benefiting from today would never have
happened so once again we're not in
danger from running out of resources
we're in danger from people who say we
got to be constrained because we're
allegedly running out of resources we're
not in danger from global warming we're
in danger from people who say we have to
be put under tyrannical governments to
avoid global warming we're not in danger
lack of Leben Strom where we've been in
danger from people who said they needed
Leben's drown okay it's always the same
thing
the fundamental argument they have is
there isn't enough to go around there
for human aspirations must be
constrained therefore someone must be
empowered to do the constraining and we
volunteer for that difficult task on
that optimistic and pessimistic note I
am Matt wells for recent TV thank you
you